[Musique]
2980 17e kilomètre il fait 40 degrés le
bitume de la ra louey me brûle les pieds
voilà trente trois jours que je suis
parti de signer et que je coure 95 à 100
km par jour
le bush australien le kram car même les
kangourous une sorte pas par cette
température ils sont pas fous 2980 17e
kilomètre ma fatigue est extrême
mon corps m'envoie des signaux d'alerté
en permanence mais j'écoute plus rien je
suis au bord de la rupture
en réalité je subis 2009 197 m km
j'arrive au ravitaillement je suis lent
extrêmement lent mon pied tape sur un
minuscule caillou est une nouvelle fois
je trébuche mais cette fois je
m'effondre tout mais barrière l'acheter
en même temps mentalement fille
psychologiquement je suis out
physiquement je suis out mes pensées
partent en live mon corps crime et mes
yeux se brouillent
et c'est une pluie de larmes qui jaillit
que je ne peux ou que je ne veux arrêter
j'ai peur peur de ne pas être capable de
terminer ce périple fou la traversée du
continent australien en courant
j'ordonne à mon corps de repartir et ce
dernier l'effrontée me répond non
j'ai peur et ça ne me ressemble pas une
partie de mon équipe et l'agent micky
immédiatement me serre dans ses bras et
trouve les justement ce qui apaise et
puis à thomas thomas qui me tend la main
thomas qui me regardent avec une lumière
et une intensité dans les yeux que je
n'avais encore jamais perçu thomas qui
me sourit et là là il se passe quelque
chose d'incroyable alors que mon corps
ne voulait plus réagir je me vois avec
l'aide de thomas en train de me relever
et jolie dans ses yeux
t'inquiète pas philippe ça va bien se
passer on n'a aucun doute surfer taille
au bout du
filles on est fier de toi on est fier de
ta compagne et on a confiance en toi et
puis merci un merci pour ce morceau de
vie ce périple dingue j'ai lu tout ça
dans les yeux de thomas dans la seule
seconde où il m'a aidé à me relever et
je suis reparti en courant et évidemment
j'ai bouclé cette transcontinentale de
3000km 3800 km alors j'ai longtemps
réfléchi à cette seconde irréel est
incroyable et je n'ai trouvé qu'une
seule réponse à la magie du moment
nous étions tous dans un amour profond
du projet commun et cet amour intense
nous a permis d'obtenir la charge
émotionnelle nécessaire à l'extinction
de ma peur et à la réussite du projet
alors depuis j'ai adopté définitivement
ce verbe aimer comme briques de
construction de ma vie et vous l'avez
vous adoptez ce magnifique verbe ne vous
trompez pas je suis un lambda je suis un
monsieur tout le monde
je suis comme toi toi ou encore mais
c'est vrai j'ai voulu une vie multiple
riche intense et colorié je suis marié
papa de trois superbes enfants une vie
de famille passionnée et passionnante
car celle qui m'accompagne illumine ma
vie et mes trois enfants sont rois
magnifique soleil en devenir et je suis
aussi entrepreneur depuis plus de 30 ans
et puis sportif et puis aventurier et
puis auteur et conférencier autant de
vies vécues avec ce que je nomme une
passion exacerbée et ça les amis
s'appellent l'amour cette passion
exacerbée a été une si ce n'est la plaie
déterminante de mon parcours
elle m'a permis des passages de vie hors
cadre des moments d'intenses émotions
comme nous devrions tous en vivres par
centaines si toutefois nous n'avions pas
le pied sur le frein en permanence grâce
à cette passion exacerbée
outre la traversée de l'australie j'ai
couru au pôle nord en antarctique par
moins 40 degrés et puis j'ai traversé la
vallée de la mort aux états unis
par plus 50 degrés cette fois et bien
d'autres périples encore depuis plus de
15 ans cette passion exacerbée m'a
permis de parcourir la planète pour
rencontrer l'inaccessible pour en
réalité vivent mes rêves
s'il ya bien longtemps que j'ai compris
qu'il fallait mieux vivre ses rêves
que rêver sa vie il ya une phrase
magnifique de jean giono qui explique
bien ça on a dû te dire qu'il fallait
réussir dans la vie
moi je te dis qu'il faut vivre c'est la
plus grande réussite au monde
mais jean giono a tout compris vivre
vivre et vivre encore ne plus subir
arrêté d'arrêter pour un oui pour un non
alors pourquoi est ce si difficile de
vivre passionnément frais pour une
raison très simple
l'homme est un froussard il a peur de
tout ils doutent il craint il tergiverse
ils hésitent ils paniquent pour un oui
pour un non
il se trouve toujours de belle excuse
par exemple en 1989 quand j'ai créé ma
première entreprise alors là j'avais
toutes les raisons d'hésiter qu'ils
n'avaient pas d'argent je n'avais aucune
connaissance
j'avais pas de réseau j'avais pas de
j'avais rien alors les autres me traiter
de fou de singles et d'inconscient voire
de stupide si jamais que toi tu n'as pas
peur les autres vont te transmettre la
leur la peur en réalité elle s'inflige
par petites touches régulière suffit
pour ça de regarder la télé de d'écouter
la radio ou de lire la presse pour être
imprégné dès le lever du jour de peur
limitantes en fait la peur fait juste
partie du programme
la peur elle est présente pour nous
guider
et c'est même un excellent indicateur de
performance je voudrais pour mon
expliquez vous citez un très grand
philosophe que j'adore que vous
connaissez certainement une phrase qui
commence par tout ce qui ne me tue pas
ah non monsieur me rend plus fort ça
c'est nietzsche qui a dit ça ce trop
compliqué pour moi je préfère l'autre
grand philosophe l'autre mike horn
ce grand aventurier a tout compris tout
ce qui ne me tue pas me fait grandir
et oui grandir ça doit être notre seul
objectif de vie alors si tu as peur de
quelque chose de quelqu'un d'un
événement dis toi bien que c'est normal
ça fait partie du jeu alors plutôt que
de le faire des noeuds à l'estomac et de
réduire tally une seule et unique
question à se poser pourquoi ai-je peur
pourquoi est-ce cette alerte automatique
qui s'allument qui a la gentillesse de
me prévenir
et puis tu analyses et puis tu agis
nouveau plan d'actions nouvelles
rencontres nouveaux apprentissages
nouveau terrain de jeu et tu vas te
rends tu compte que tes peurs sont
culturelles et comme la plupart du temps
parfaitement infondées le général
desportes un de nos grands stratèges
militaires dit souvent une phrase que je
me suis approprié tellement je trouve
juste tu dois embrasser l'incertitude
tu te rendras compte ainsi que les
innombrables contraintes qui jalonnent
la vie sont en réalité deux magnifiques
opportunités à exploiter
et oui vous savez pourquoi j'ai pas peur
pas peur de parler devant vous
aujourd'hui parce que je ne crains pas
votre regard je ne crains pas votre
jugement
et pour une raison très simple je ne
vous veux aucun mal
je ne veux vous transmettre que
l'exaltation de l'enthousiaste de
l'énergie la passion de l'amour en fait
80 % de nos peurs 80% sont articulées
autour de ses deux simples concepts le
regard de l'autre et le jugement alors
nous savons tous ont porté nos efforts
il n'y a pas besoin de chercher midi à
quatorze heures en réalité c'est très
simple si je devais vous donné un seul
conseil pour gérer ses peurs ne restez
jamais seul
trouvez vous un binôme quelqu'un qui
vous ayez une confiance xxl former des
cercles proches de valeur ne vous
laissez jamais ne se laissait jamais
personne rentrer dans un cercle que vous
n'avez pas décidé savez seul jamais
j'aurais été au pôle nord jamais
j'aurais été en antarctique seul mais
mais pour rien au monde eut raté
traverser l'australie au courant mais
accompagnés et bien accompagné j'y suis
allé avec l'amour que l'on porte à nos
projets l'amour véritable de ceux qui
nous accompagnent l'amour profond sur le
regard qu'on porte sur le monde
nous renvoyons nos peurs au fond du
placard et nous allumons d'innombrables
lumières qui nous permettent de voir le
monde avec une autre brillance une autre
lumière un autre visage celui de la
passion celui du plaisir celui de l'an
viii et ça ça change tout alors bien sûr
beaucoup me mettre en garde contre les
dangers d'une passion exacerbée la
passion taurin avec philippe la démesure
toujours la démesure
voilà où on te monette et passion si tu
continues tu vas te faire mal de
détruire pour beaucoup je suis excessif
jeu devrait ralentir un peu réduire la
voilure être plus raisonnable mais
raisonnable par rapport à quoi par
rapport à qui au modèle qui nous sont
présentés je n'approuve pas à la
normalité de l'instant elle m'ennuie à
la à la bienséance non stop stop
la passion c'est mon moteur et
j'aimerais tellement qu'il devienne le
vôtre grâce à elle ça fait plus de
cinquante neuf ans que je m'amuse 59 ans
ma vie et hop
alors bien sûr bien sûr comme vous tous
il ya eu des hauts il ya eu débat
ça n'a pas toujours été tendre le chemin
a souvent été sinueux des fois
verglacées et pour être tout à fait
honnête j'ai de temps à autres frôlé la
sortie de route
mais il ya une chose que je garde en
permanence en tête et que vous devez
garder en tête tout le temps nous sommes
les maîtres d'oeuvre de notre vie c'est
nous qui décidons si nous qui dirigeons
et personne d'autre une fois que cette
simple vérité est acquise et ancré dans
notre tête à l'heure la vie devient
passionnément jouissive et intense
si je devais vous donner qu'un seul
conseil pour arriver à cela commencez
par vous aimez vous même retrouvé la
confiance que vous avez perdu l'estimé
de vous vous êtes toutes et tous chargés
d' incroyable talent oscar wilde disait
la plus belle histoire d'amour n'a pu à
l'histoire d'amour c'est ça c'est
s'aimer soi même c'est une histoire
d'amour qui durera toute une vie eh oui
commencez par vous aimez chercher vos
potentiels cacher trouver le bouton
power et surtout surtout appuyé dessus
vous savez des amis la vie c'est une
succession d'actions que nous menons
petites grandes folles saugrenue
enchanté belle intimiste public
terrifiant tous magnifiques peu importe
elles sont toutes là pour une seule et
unique une seule chose nous rendre
heureux
nous devons aimer sans modération les
actions que nous menons
même si elles sont complexes même si
elle me perturbe car aimer ce que l'on
fait c'est tout simplement accéder au
bonheur
voilà pourquoi j'ai décidé d'adopter ce
verbe aimer comme briques de
construction de ma vie et que je vous
incite à en faire de même pour qu'au
final nous puissions tous dire j'ai
grandi toute ma vie et c'était vraiment
génial belle route à vous tous merci
[Applaudissements]